[Musik]
er befürchte es kräftigt sie war fertig
ist ist fertig nach deiner erlaubnis
monika harms isaca bin überzeugt dass es
weitergeht nachdem dort ist kanzlerin
verzerrt wird automatisch seine maschine
ihnen trinkt oder hanni de france kann
eine spirituelle esoterischen china
behauptet amerika oder in religiöse
ihnen
ich bin einfach plötzlich verwahrt
unsere tiefe bewusstlosigkeit und mit
dem hochgefühl sehr durchdringend er
sterbe ich bin am sterbe ich bin sofort
glücklich wurde also einfach nur so
allerlei das liegt das ist so vertraut
sie also die lichtvolle und es ist noch
was sie erlebte ich so viel größer als
das was mir bevorsteht zusammen diesem
hobby wird nicht sehr viel besser aber
der schleier vor immer noch platzen
was passiert wenn wir sterben davon
berichten menschen die mit einem fuß wie
inside standen
[Musik]
marcel goc ist materialwart beim
erstliga verein ehc burgdorf sowie dem
eishockey verbunden bleiben
marcel gasser war ein viel
versprechendes eishockey talent er
träumte davon profisportler zu werden
dann hatte er mit anfang zwanzig einen
motorradunfall
danach war alles anders rang ab
warum frau merkel dass sie mit dem
gleichgewicht problem haben mit mit der
eu das ganze zeug das ich das nur
stammen die woche machen haben wir
leider gottes volk karriere bernanke und
das war ein reines gold macht
eindrucksvoll dass er fast gestorben
wäre hat marcel gaza verändert er sei
auch zahmer geworden liebe intensiver
und mache sich nützlich wo er könne ja
glück war dass sie weder von red bull
hofft jahre quasi geschenkt und ihres
hauses st und versuche so glücklich wie
möglich
[Applaus]
sein lebenstraum platzte mit anfang 20
trotzdem morgen mit ende vierzig nicht
klagen
wieso auch er sei am leben
[Applaus]
passiert ist der unfall ist fast 30
jahre hier aber die erinnerungen daran
leben wird delio rossi mixa in bedburg
sowie das haus realisiert hat es gesagt
es macht extrem komisch und samy dort
lag was oder wie hans gefühlt als ob ich
mich fast um wasser löst vor allem was
man nicht denn plötzlich ihnen art
trudel ka und dann ihnen weiter gesunken
fortgerissen wie ein fluss seit dem
moment wo mit körper bis zum stillstand
ruhig wirkt wie soziales als bei der
tour war und plötzlich ist zucker aber
nicht ganz so witzig sagt wie denn jetzt
klick gemacht
ich panik regierungssprecher und dann
eine kraft einfach alles ganz gut ich
bin nicht stärker als die kraft
franz könig war kadermann in einer
kantonalen verwaltung seit seiner
frühpensionierung wieder mit der sicht
im überirdischen also thema den sitzen
bleiben
nachdem die frau den einzigen betrieb
dann das ist eine existenzielle frage
und es ist aber vor unsere jugend so
immer sehr interessiert
der grund wieso dass ich jetzt sollte
die jenes forschungen machen
er selber hat die eine nahtoderfahrung
aber er hat schon dutzende von menschen
besucht die fast gestorben wären
menschen wie magnolien bless mit seiner
videoausrüstung zeichnete die gespräche
auf das ergebnis veröffentlicht franz
könig im internet daran verdient er
nichts
er möchte dass sich viele mit dem thema
befassen können im ferienort den dort
man sich ja ums land cremona umreißt um
sich da an schien überrascht
das spare und das wirklich grund wieso
dass man sich damit befassen
frau bläst sie erlebten innerhalb von 20
jahren eine nahtoderfahrung wie kann das
ich war unterwegs mit meinem vater in
seinem autor er war am steuer
wir wollen nach hause und da kam mit
großer geschwindigkeit von der
gegenüberliegenden seite also uns
entgegen
ein auto rund fünf prozent der menschen
machen im laufe ihres lebens eine
sogenannte nahtoderfahrung aber nur
wenige reden darüber als spender abstand
pluto war dagegen wieder als
unglaubwürdig abstand total also schau
es ist schon schwierig über das können
jetzt hoffen sie hat angst dass sich
nicht verständlich zu machen
gute qualität dafür hätte darüber noch
20 erfahrung mit 80 macht unsere
gesellschaft
das stimmt das ist das thema wo die
brust landete
warum das durch es macht auch keine
angst
angesprochen ist
franz könig hat ein weiteres interview
im kasten einmal mehr wurde ihm das ende
des lebens aus wunderschön geschildert
insgesamt bemühen wie immer sollte die
person in der wohnung aktiver fahrer
sind sehr gefasst zehntausende teilweise
gar hunderttausende schauen sich front
unix interviews an interviews mit
menschen die mit einem fuß im jenseits
standen interessieren offenbar jede zeit
verstorbene haag jährige und wenn er
weiß dass die verstorbene eltern
geistige welt gut empfangen während das
sie betreut wäre das ein rekord gott
denn nach ist deshalb für die
hinterbliebenen trost und der hilfe also
im prinzip ist das alles hilft es ist
ein sich wiederholendes element in den
erfahrungsberichten der sterbende bleibe
nicht lange allein
[Musik]
und plötzlich sie mehr gestalt an und
zwar ein ziemlich vivi kola kreis des
vaters mini großmutter daher kann ganz
strahlend und glücklich und leuchtend
und dann die plötzliche bewegung wagner
rechtsform im bett wo ihr der kopf
streitig
aber er ist nicht menschlich gesehen
ganz sie also gut gefüllt mit licht
gesehen und sofort deine rica ist wer
das ist nicht was ich jetzt könnte der
klaren wort wer das gesehen aber das
gefühl wir mini familie wieder kunden ja
nicht kennt jetzt waren in der nähe
kennt es ist alles ganz toll erkenne ich
sie im rat fangen miteinander
kommunizieren nicht mental nicht
telepathischer nicht verbal sondern wie
hier vor hier vom herzen kommunikation
über die eigentlich nicht zu kennen also
hier und bestritt dass wir die user so
beschrieben
sie ist einfach klasse so wie sie es
lesen und miss wiese an sich muss
durchschnittlicher besinnen heckflosse
und während das klassische anhimmeln
verstanden überquert und über die liebe
und über den sinn und die haben mich
einer loslachen verstanden alles ist gut
letzlich an ihm ist ganz lieber nochmals
von mir ablauf war ganz schnell alles
fast zu gehen wie fast in der kugel ist
nach schule passiert ist ich dass ich in
bezirke aufgeteilt
sie sind also formiert lager besonders
auf das spiel es ist so klar wurde dass
das auch im bezirk im labor hey sind
aber wir sind noch ganz gut 6
normalerweis fahrt mal wieder der
bobbahn man hat diese 2 wendt links und
rechts um vater einfach aber jetzt
plötzlich kann darüber dass sei und sein
hengst fahrer nicht sehen
wil im kanton st gallen
hier hat es die promovierte historikerin
aktuell in place immer wieder gezogen
sie hat die geschichte dieser stadt
studiert und vieles darüber geschrieben
fragen des glaubens haben sie zeitlebens
beschäftigt die rund 850 jahre alte
villa madonna etwa fasziniert sie noch
heute eine sagenumwobene kultfigur die
immer wieder wunder vollbracht haben
soll
ich glaube dass liebe und weisheit
grundprinzip sind vorläufig vom mensch
von cosmos vor allem unter sich sein
werk fast denn was man gott nennt es ist
ein geist ex prinzip unfassbar aber es
ist da und wirkt sich immer aus
[Musik]
ihr halbes leben hat magda im westin
bestens erhaltenen historischen quellen
von wil gewidmet sie fand erfüllung im
eintauchen in längst vergangene zeiten
und sie teilte ihre passion stets gerne
etwa mit den zuschauern des inzwischen
eingestellten wieder statt fernsehens
besser weil man entwicklungstrend wenn
man weiß wer was entstanden ist wir sind
immer noch nur die schultern unserer
vorherige generationen und dir auch
wieder auf der schulter von denen und
vieles bewusst oder unbewusst wieder und
vieles versteht man in der welt besser
wenn wir geschichte und ihr mit dass man
kennt desto kleiner wird die
mosaiksteine kann seine sätze vieles
versteht man mit der zeit besser und
vieles bleibt ein mysterium irgendwo
eine ganz ganz liegt es also ist es
pünktlich sein und habe ich sogar
mittelpunkt
krampfhaft aber was ist dieser punkt
setzt der rückwärtsbewegung und die pisa
nicht mehr aufgegangen
und dass die explosion die zwei
explosion ist so dass ich wieder
jubelschreie
es ist viel mehr als sie es hatte
unglaubliche wärme und liebe ausströmt
und der unglaubliche weisheit und der
wisse
es ist der inbegriff von absolut access
ist lebendig passiert und
mehrschichtiges licht wo ich als
verschnitt anders als im juni
es ist lebendig sie das licht es hat
vibriert vor energie ganz subtile
energie und kreativität wird würde ich
sagen es ist ein sieg ich bin kein
sportchef ich weiß nicht einfach absolut
bewusst sie ebenfalls bewusst sie was
ich so kurz glück sie enthält sie ein
seminarzentrum in der nähe von wien
kurz wir starten mit voller tun nehmen
uns richtig schön zeit ramon gott man
sagt er sei lebens coach er helfe
menschen in gruppen oder einzeln ihr
einzigartiges und wunderschönes wesen zu
entdecken und die furcht vor ihren
schatten und ihrem nicht zu verlieren
[Musik]
ohne seine intensive nahtoderfahrung
undenkbar dass es verstanden ist darüber
was bin ich ganz tief innen hinderte
bilder und hinderte wurde ich über mich
an das ist ein spiritueller erfreulicher
deshalb später gibt die reds bruchteile
natur bevor ich damit durch noch
gewerkelt das also im praktischen
einsatz finden wie ich und moderne
moritz flucht
in diesem mehrtägigen kurs einem
sogenannten retreat sollen die
teilnehmerinnen laut gartmann zur ruhe
kommen sich selbst begegnen und die
magie ihrer inneren welt erleben
allgemein verstecken wir diese sehr viel
hinter der maske
tatsächlich will mir die füße nicht
klappt dass man schön klug sind sowieso
einfach zeigen wer wir sind und dann so
dort liegt zu bekommen werde und da wir
der moment wo keiner ob machens zu
servieren kontakt mit der schönheit sie
vor mehreren monaten akzeptieren dass
ich schön beginn als reale andere er
wolle mithelfen die welt ein bisschen
besser zu machen eine welt in die er
nach seinem zwölf meter tiefen sturz von
einem dach im auto von acht jahren
eigentlich gar nicht zurück wollte und
sich für dich wieder zum zug
ich kann nicht zurück und dann hätte
sich die nie einseitig rasch entscheiden
zumindest zug konnte nicht aber ich
möchte dir gerne bis zeigen bevor du
dich entscheiden und dann hat er mich
mit gesetzlich eingeführt wird oder vor
hangar und dann sehen wir bitten die
telefonische welt gesehen hat plötzlich
hatte mir überlegt was sie eigentlich
der erde entlang
wenn jetzt gar was lange eigentlich
zurück ich möchte nicht zurück in afrika
stammt von mir und dem wunderbaren
moment vor dem club von der begegnung
mit den worten stockt und ich eine
störens wird mein name und merkt das ist
mein vater wurde sie nicht die man kennt
und die hat merkt dass er im höchster
verzweiflung ist in panik
plötzlich anhang sport durch mehrere und
an über blut und haare ist das taxi war
vor gut zwanzig ort stolpern ist wie man
kein terawatt hat strauß und 18 studio
unfall kam
ja was wir machen hatte die cs netto
du musst zurück ich bin im krankenwagen
klage haben vogelperspektive hat seine
de wie sie probiert mich ja wie sie sich
um mich kümmert einfach wissen probiert
und michael etter und dann hat das
wissen meine aufmerksamkeit auf der
hintere teil richtet vom frank abaca
muskeln geht es nach mixas und dann habe
ich jede schwarz gesehen und das was
glück die tour mit dem momentanen nix
endlich als gewünscht als etablierte
tauchen aber seine hand wieder seine
angst gespürt und denke haben das
plastische volk stellt in der partei
wird fertigung sind brillen dalí wie man
halt immer junge mensch bildet noch mehr
als wenn ein alter moskau wenn ich die
entscheide mich wo ich will zurück und
unmittelbar sei gemacht und ich bin
gerade bringt sie und b im völlig
gesunden körper von einem unfall als
wach wurde noch einmal will bin ich aber
dann mit der verdacht immer schaukelnde
fährt und dann hat ein freundlicher
mensch gehört sie nicht der website
heißt sie und die welle krankenkasse
sind sie ist so schmunzelt eigentlich
lachen
jetzt bin ich wieder da jetzt hat mir
werte wieder
[Musik]
andrea pfeifer kommt zurück ins leben
weil sie noch etwas zu teilen hatte mit
der welt ihre musik
[Musik]
es hat mit der emission für kunde also
das mini musik und das ist jesus wurde
[Musik]
nämlich gerade lebt das gefühl wird
monika lass dir ganz toll das möchte das
[Musik]
endziel quasi ist gut es ist
früher machte sie musik war aber zu
schüchtern damit an die öffentlichkeit
zu gehen
heute spielt in einer band namens
alvarion und tritt auf
[Musik]
dass sie beinahe an einer
lebensmittelvergiftung gestorben wäre
hat alles verändert sogar ihre
wahrnehmung ganz oft wenn ihr begegnen
und die logi-methode der verwandlung wo
ich ganz viele verschiedene
informationen ist denn so als ob ich
habe ja ich sehe uns für verschiedene
formen
[Gelächter]
wenn ich sie jetzt um die spiele gesehen
nicht verschiedene geschichten voller
energie um sie um einfach da sind wir
ein sehr transparentes er transparenz
glasgow in bewegung ist oder was ist für
dich nur besser dass sie intuitiver
worden bin vor allem mit der erste jahr
hat das gefühl manchmal so annika und
erkläre ich spüre relativ schnell buchen
was kann die buche schlagen
der märkte die meisten station der biss
der hund biss passiert wo könnte im
umfeld zu fromms unix sammelt fleißig
weiter interviews für seinen youtube
kanal namens empirische jenseits
forschung
diejenigen die öffentlich über ihre
blicke ins jenseits redeten hätten eine
gemeinsame motivation sagte er
sie selber hinzu lebt das sie liebevoll
empfangen worden sind das ist dass ihr
wunderschönes gefühl kann wenn sie
brauchen sind und da wenn sie der
anderen blogger tmn thalia vorm sterben
viele schulmediziner sind indes
überzeugt dass es ganz simple
erklärungen gebe für solche erfahrungen
etwa sauerstoffmangel zu viel
kohlendioxid oder chemische reaktionen
im gehirn
[Musik]
zumal besonders meiner es auch vom hirn
ich glaube wenn wir so lautet die frage
einfach was gut nachvollziehen dass es
angst macht das macht immer angst wenn
man grund viele weltsicht in frage
stellt wahr ist was erlaubt ist was ist
da muss ein thema und das zählt für mich
klang oder weniger sieht man eigentlich
ja und sind zu wenig gross hat uns die
nation ist schweifen und einmal
irgendetwas a dog monat vorher erlebt
hat oder sowie treiben die hand hat
irgendein setzte den träumen von dem was
man erlebt natürlich am tag oder jeden
tag aber nato der fall ist
unvergleichlich viel intensiver
marcel gasser hat sich als hauswart und
ein mann putz betrieb über wasser dann
kam das khroma virus und ihn brauchen
fast alle einnahmen weg was eigentlich
immer das getan hat und mir probiert
sich mit engagiert aber man hat ja danke
es geht um familie drängen also darum
gegangen die andere weil ihm sein
verstorbener vater sagte ist eine zeit
sei noch nicht gekommen geht marcel gast
davon aus dass er noch gebraucht werde
auf dieser welt weil ich stark wie nie
aufgab man einen notruf geht und wer
hilft ihnen
und vielleicht ist das auch klappt ist
aber schwierig sein beruf zähler
also ich habe bis dato nie mehr zum
beispiel warum erwachsene familienvater
verantwortlich und muss doch sauber
locker dass sie ist am ganze zirkus
aroma dass er nicht weiß wie er und
seine familie in den kommenden monaten
über die runden kommen sollen setzt ihm
zu auch wenn er versucht es sich nicht
anmerken zu lassen
finanzielle sorgen begleiten ihn schon
ein leben lang
er hat immer gearbeitet und nie viel
verdient aber so schlimm wie jetzt war
es noch selten er steht vor dem nichts
letzte show jeden moment gewusst bereut
dass sie wieder zurück sind glaube ich
schon froh wenn ich wieder zurückkommen
und darf das außenlager hier aber king
zu wachsen
brüssel
[Musik]
rottmann ist ende 30 und mit celina
verheiratet mit der er zwei kleine
kinder hat
sie verbringen so viel zeit wie möglich
zusammen machen fast alles gemeinsam
mehr braucht er nicht zu seinem glück
für mich fertig mit der familie vor
allem mit kindern
also ich kannte ihn klären und so
beginnt das meine ich einfach so im
augenblick sie selbst schon viel mit der
fahrgast das ist also die der nato der
fahrer gar nicht merkt was bedeutet
völlig im moment sie mir bitte die dinge
nicht darauf achten dass der ufa
kletterin jetzt machen wir's petri parat
film ist eine nahtod erfahrung machte
ihm bewusst wie schnell alles enden kann
irgendwann wird beim tod kommen
vielleicht ist im hohen alter aber
vielleicht auch schon morgen
wir merken dass ich es kann mache also
dass sie kann entscheiden wir jetzt will
oder nicht würde ich jeden fall da bin
und wenn punktsieg für merkel ist jetzt
einfach so wenn wir die musik ja aber
ich genieße so mega das hast du nicht
weniger
marcel gasse muss einen weiteren
schicksalsschlag verkraften
er hatte vor wenigen tagen einen
schlaganfall
was ist realisiert haben was eigentlich
passiert ist und wie knapp das will ich
aktiv fahrt ein da sie ja wie schnell
das eigentlich fertig sie frau plötzlich
einen seite kriegen um nach aktuell aber
ich glaube nicht einmal dass sie ist und
angst dass man die chance hat muss man
halt warten
das ist und das klima belastet hat aus
dass es kommt fertig wenn das ist fertig
ist weiß marianne wenn sie angst vor dem
tod ich habe angst verrückt oder im
gegenteil oft im staate liga noch einmal
zurück in das erlebnis ich weiß sie dem
moment wo ich wirklich los war
wenn ich es einfach okay im schnitt
leben stirbt wird abkommt und das ist so
schmerzvoll aber mit gewissen punkt wird
das bewusst sie sich öffnet ich denke
das präludium chance so faszinierend ist
so fantastisch
das konzert war noch einen grund nun
noch schöner sie schon angst vor job zu
wechseln oder den wohnort und mehr was
man aus dem red das ganze komplett
lassen
als das ganze aber das konstrukt und
aufbauten
das glaube ich
innen schwierig ich freue mich
eigentlich auf der toten wollen jetzt
noch nicht ich habe jetzt noch sehr gern
und hoffe dass das noch nicht so schnell
ist aber der tod ist sicher bis ein
großartiger übergang wo denn sie in dem
moment 13 vom universum entschlüsseln
gut möglich allerdings dass uns auf
erden noch viel dunkelheit erwartet
bevor uns im jenseits das licht empfängt
[Musik]